anthony scaramucci is one of the best
known financiers in the world and he now
owns hundreds of millions of dollars of
bitcoin via his asset management firm
sky bridge well yesterday at the bitcoin
conference he made a bold prediction
anthony predicted that both candidates
in the 2024 presidential election will
be pro bitcoin don't take it from me
though here's exactly what he said
elizabeth warren who i think is very
misinformed trying to put negative
information in and so so they didn't do
either why they had a waterfall of phone
calls coming into washington telling
them to stop
next piece because you guys know i i got
my 11 day phd in washington
yeah i can tell you how these people
operate follow the money okay you got so
much money coming in from lobbyists
trade associations etc i'll predict
right here 2024 both presidential
candidates will be pro bitcoiners and
pro blockchain scaramucci's got a point
here politicians are realizing both on
the left and the right that the bitcoin
and crypto community is one that they're
gonna have to pay attention to there are
tens of millions of americans that own
bitcoin one of the crypto elite sam
bankman freed was actually the second
largest donor to the joe biden
presidential campaign on top of that
when the infrastructure bill actually
got put forward they were flooded with
phone calls tweets and emails
the bitcoin and crypto community has
made their voice hurt they've got a lot
of money they've got a lot of influence
and with so many americans holding these
assets at a time when they're getting
pushed into a dire financial position
americans don't want politicians to mess
with their money and ultimately every
politician is going to realize being pro
bitcoin pro cryptocurrencies that is
going to be the only way to get elected
and to keep your political seat hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time